President Trump is headed home from
Paris with the Russia investigations
still hanging over his administration
and his family the president and first
lady watched a military parade this
morning celebrating Bastille Day the
French national holiday it was the last
event of a two-day visit with French
president and Manuel McCraw while in
Paris mr. Trump responded to questions
about his oldest son's attempt to
collect damaging campaign information
about Hillary Clinton from Russian
sources Mark Phillips is along the
parade route on the shomsul is a mark
good morning good morning well Donald
Trump may enjoy a parade as much as
anyone else but behind the marching
bands here was the drumbeat of the
alleged Russian collusion scandal that
continues to dog this presidency it's a
great show of French and also this year
of American power a grand parade
celebrating two great historic events
might seem like a good place to forget
about those niggling concerns back home
but those concerns paraded along the
songs Alizee with French and American
troops here to commemorate the French
Revolution and the entry of the u.s.
into World War one a hundred years ago
the meeting during the election campaign
between the president's son Donald Jr
and a Russian lawyer promising dirt on
Hillary Clinton has hung over this visit
like a cloud of bad news as far as my
son is concerned my son is a wonderful
young man the president had to spend a
large part of his time here defending
his son the meeting produced no useful
dirt he said and was just part of the
nasty business of politics
it's called opposition research or even
research into your opponent I have only
been in politics for two years but I've
had many people call up oh gee we have
information on this factor or this
person or frankly Hillary the Russian
scandal is just one of the president's
problems here he was also given a
history
the u.s. entry into World War one began
a century of involvement in European
affairs that many feared Donald Trump is
trying to reduce just as he is ending
the American involvement in the Paris
Accords to try to limit the effects of
climate change on that perhaps to offer
some encouragement to his host French
President Emmanuel macron he dangled the
slim prospect he might change his mind
yeah I mean something could happen with
respect to the Paris Accord we'll see
what happens this was supposed to be a
quick and easy little trip to
commemorate history instead it turned
into an intense political drama very
much of the troubles of today nothing
seems to be easy for this white house
lately mark Phillips in Paris thank you